(snowmobile engine)
(light music)
- [Voiceover] A lot of people call this
the Dr. Seuss house.
- First of all, nobody asked Dr. Seuss
for permission to do that.
They refer to that because of some
of the ideas that Dr. Seuss had.
I think he was a genius,
and I think he did a lot
of good for the world.
I try and write poetry,
and I kind of think of
this as a poem to the sky.
I am Phillip Paul Weidner,
I'm the owner and builder
of Goose Creek Tower.
I went to MIT, and I'm kind
of a frustrated architect,
so I like building. I just
designed it out of my head,
we didn't have blueprints,
we drew it out on cardboard,
plywood, just as we were going.
What I'm going to end
up doing, eventually,
is put some hooks here and
hang pots and pans off them,
because this is the kitchen.
I started to build a
40-by-40 ascribed log cabin,
and I realized I could put pillars on top,
and put another house on top a house.
And I just kept going,
we got to 185 feet and we stopped,
because 200 feet is federal air space.
Now I just have to finish it out.
This is pretty much the last real stairs.
There are multiple levels in there,
and I've tried to count them,
and it's just impossible.
It depends on how you count stories.
(light music)
I wanted to be able to see,
and that's the reason I went up.
You can actually see
for at least 300 miles,
and of course, when the
Northern Lights are out,
you can really see.
(light music)
I hope that Goose Creek Tower
will inspire other people,
to do worthwhile things,
not just in building,
but whatever they do with their life.
And every time I go up there
it's a different experience.
It kind of gives you a sense of the
enormity of the universe.
(light music)